probably the most ironic aspect of all
this is that the Adventist Church itself
meets this definition of Babylon
perfectly having engaged with sdas on
this level for years now they're some of
the most doctrinately divided people
I've ever engaged with every one of them
seems to be the objective standard of
what true adventism is which doctrines
are essential and how each Doctrine is
to be understood
[Music]
the channel
viewing our Series today in Examining
The Gospel of Jesus Christ up and
against the seven-day Adventist Three
Angels gospel if you missed the previous
two parts I suggest you check those out
first the link for both of those is in
the description box down below so in
part one we talked about this phrase the
Everlasting gospel that they have
latched on to from Revelation 14 6 and
we looked at what all they mean by that
in part two we talked about the first
Angels message the investigative
judgment and today we're going to get
into the second Angel's message let's
quickly look at Revelation 14 8 and then
get into how they interpret and apply
this it says
another Angel a second followed saying
Fallen Fallen is Babylon the great she
who made all nations drink the wine of
The Passion of her sexual immorality so
they interpret this second Angel's
message as a call for Christians
attending non-advanist churches to leave
those churches and join the one true
Remnant which they claim is themselves
Ellen White writes in multiple places
that the early sdas believed that this
prophecy was fulfilled in 1844 when some
Christians left their churches to unite
with the millerite movement in spiritual
gifts volume 4 Page 234 she writes this
when the churches spurned the counsel of
God by rejecting the Advent message the
Lord rejected them the first Angel was
followed by a second proclaiming Babylon
has fallen is Fallen that great City
because she made all nations drink of
the wine of the wrath of her fornication
this message was understood by
Adventists to be an announcement of the
moral fall of the churches and
consequence of the rejection of the
first message
so the churches that rejected William
Miller's fanaticism about the imminent
return of Christ were labeled as Babylon
and Ellen claims they were rejected by
God for rejecting William Miller's
message a message that was not only
completely wrong but one that Miller
himself eventually admitted to being
false since 1844 all non-adventist
churches are supposedly rejected by God
and the Holy Spirit has been withdrawn
from them but she didn't end there she
tells us in early writings page 260 that
Christians in non-sda churches cannot be
benefited by Christ's intercession their
prayers are useless and Satan is now in
control of them a bit of a long quote
here but she writes
those who rejected the first message
could not be benefited by the second
neither were they benefited by the
Midnight Cry which was to prepare them
to enter with Jesus by faith into the
most holy place of the Heavenly
sanctuary and by rejecting the two
former messages they have so darkened
their understanding that they can see no
light in the third Angel's message which
shows the way into the most holy place I
saw that as the Jews crucified Jesus so
the nominal churches had crucified these
messages and therefore they have no
knowledge of the way into the most holy
and they cannot be benefited by the
intercession of Jesus there like the
Jews who offered their useless
sacrifices they offer up their useless
prayers to the apartment which Jesus has
left and Satan pleased with the
deception assumes a religious character
and leads the minds of these professed
Christians to himself working with his
power his signs and lying wonders to
fasten them in his snare some he
deceives in one way and some in another
he has different delusions prepared to
affect different Minds some look with
upon one deception while they
readily receive another Satan deceives
some with spiritualism he also comes as
an angel of Light and spreads his
influence over the land by means of
false reformations the churches are
elated and consider that God is working
marvelously for them when it is the work
of another spirit
so this means that any sort of Revival
that's taken place since the time of
this has been a charade and a facade God
hasn't been behind any of it all the
professed believers who have come from
these revivals have been duped by Satan
and aren't really Christians remember
this when you hear an Adventist try to
call you brother or sister but the
emphasis and focus of this second
Angel's message is on the term Babylon
like every other term they use this as
an opportunity as a trojan horse to
Hitch the wagon of baggage to Ellen
White taught that the Prophecies of
Revelation regarding Babylon apply
specifically to Protestant churches she
says this in spirit of Prophecy Vol 4 on
page 232 by saying this
the term Babylon derived from Babel and
signifying confusion is applied in
scripture to the various forms of false
or apostate religion but the message
announcing the fall of Babylon must
apply to some religious body that was
once pure and has become corrupt it
cannot be the romish church which is
here meant for that church has been in a
fallen condition for many centuries but
how appropriate the figure as applied to
the Protestant churches all professing
to derive their Doctrine from the Bible
yet divided into almost innumerable sex
the unity for which Christ prayed does
not exist instead of one Lord One Faith
one baptism there are numberless
conflicting Creeds and theories
religious Faith appears so confused and
discordant that the world know not what
to believe is truth God is not in all
this it is the work of man the work of
Satan
so if you recall some of the underlying
Adventist assumptions I mentioned in
part one well here you see one of them
on display the Adventist Church doesn't
understand denominationalism in the
Adventist mind each Protestant
denomination views themselves the way
that the Adventists view themselves they
think Baptists be themselves as the one
true church Presbyterians the same Etc
when the fact is this is not the case at
all this is a simple misunderstanding on
their part and a projection of their own
false idea onto others nevertheless as
you saw the second Angel's message has
to do with calling Protestants out of
their churches which have supposedly
fallen and become apostate the mother
Harlot of Revelation 17 is supposedly
Rome and her daughters that are drunk on
her doctrinal errors are the apostate
Protestant churches the spirit of God is
supposedly withdrawn from these local
assemblies and can be found housed in
the Adventist Church now probably the
most ironic aspect of all this is that
the Adventist Church itself meets this
definition of Babylon perfectly having
engaged with sdas on this level for
years now they're some of the most
doctrinally divided people I've ever
engaged with every one of them seems to
be the objective standard of what true
adventism is which doctrines are
essential and how each Doctrine is to be
understood the evidence of this can be
seen by just carousing the comment
sections of my videos you name the
doctrine and I'll find you 10 different
Adventists who have 10 varying opinions
but finally and we've looked at this in
detail before on the channel Ellen White
writing to an Adventist missionary in
the UK is giving advice on how to spread
the Adventist faith in this she calls
the clergy of the day worse than
heathens but says to not tell them this
outright because it will shut up the
opportunity for them in the future to
reach these types of people because
again they believe that their mission is
faced inward towards Christians this is
from manuscript releases volume 17 on
page 334 she says
the greatest Prejudice of the Jewish
nation of priests and rulers was stirred
up against Christ because the people
preferred to listen to Jesus rather than
to them the very same feelings of
prejudice will be manifest in the
priests and rulers of this time we can
do nothing that would close up the way
before us in this country like taking a
position of superiority and putting
before the people that we consider them
Heathen in truth they are worse than
Heathen but this we are not to tell them
the clergy consider themselves as
teachers highly religious and their
churches send out missionaries to the
work of converting the Savages but to
have the implication that a similar work
must be done for them they would
consider the worst kind of insult she
claimed that just like the Jewish
leaders of Jesus's day who considered
themselves to be teachers and highly
religious so do the clergy of their day
because this is the case the Adventists
aren't to take a position of superiority
by outright telling them that they are
worse than Heathen even though that's
what they actually think this would
offend them when they consider
themselves highly religious and they are
sending out their own missionaries so
for the Adventist missionary to tell
them that a war work of conversion is
also needed for them they would find
that highly offensive so Christians
understand that this is what this
organization actually thinks about you
does this sound like the gospel folks
remember this is a part of their Three
Angels gospel message the power of God
unto salvation apparently entails
leaving Protestant churches and joining
them or you're doomed how convenient
right that sounds like quite the
recruiting tactic so to recap here's
what Ellen White which the Adventist
Church is beholden to has said regarding
the second Angel's message Roman
Catholicism has fallen Protestant
denominations are Babylon God does not
hear the prayers of those in these
churches Jesus is only interceding for
Adventists any Revival outside of
adventism is a deception of Satan
non-advinist conversions to Christ are
not real God's spirit is largely
withdrawn from non-sda churches and
non-adventist Christians are worse than
Heathen like I said last time Adventists
if you are caught up in this mess we are
praying for you we do not hate you many
of us were once in the position that you
are currently this is a false gospel it
is not the actual good news of Jesus
Christ this false gospel is cursed and
it cannot save you Galatians 1 shoot me
an email and I would be glad to talk
with you further about this answer
adventism gmail.com if you enjoyed
today's video or found it helpful hit
that like button subscribe and ring the
notification Bell so you can be notified
when the fourth and final part in the
series is uploaded I'll see you guys
next time
God bless
[Music]